Guardians of the Galaxy 3 has a lot of
laughs behind the scenes of course but
also a ton of heart we get to find out
exactly how insecure Chris Pratt was
playing Star-Lord the emotional Arc of
nebula who wasn't even supposed to make
it past the first movie and just how
Technical and complex Rocket's
performances outside of the visual
effects the first MCU flop that's
basically what everyone was saying about
Guardians of the Galaxy before the first
film came out the cast was super
insecure about the movie's premiere and
their performance when filming because
there was a ton of hate for it before it
even got to the screen so obviously when
that didn't happen more like the
opposite happened everyone was really
proud for the final day of shooting
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 Chris Pratt
gave a pretty hilarious speech when he
read all of those hate clippings about
the movie you know say hey we overcame a
lot to get where we are and and boy we
weren't supposed to be what we are
obviously it was quite the emotion
national day for everyone involved when
we think Star-Lord we will always think
of Chris Pratt James Gunn felt the same
way as soon as he walked in for his
audition before Chris he went through
dozens and dozens of different auditions
trying to find the right fit but before
Chris Pratt's audition even began he
knew right away that he was the one it's
meant so much it was like being drafted
onto a winning NFL team or something you
know something interesting about this
hand and glove Vibe when James Gunn
found Chris for Star-Lord was the fact
that nobody else saw him playing the
role there was one particular article he
saw before his audition the 25 actors we
could see playing Star-Lord and I wasn't
on it I was none of them were me kind of
funny how these things end up working
out thank God that James saw something
to me and and wanted to make me the
character it's actually crazy to think
that Karen Gillen signed up for this
role thinking that her entire shoot
process would be eight days long and
that nebula wouldn't even live through
the first film now here I am nine years
ten years later and I'm an official
Guardian so yeah they rewrote her ending
not once but twice ultimately deciding
not to cut her out of the film which
obviously we love because of that alone
Karen was super emotional when she saw
the script for the third film she
actually shed quite a few tears because
of it but we read it and just like both
were crying together but there was also
tears of laughter too not to Hype it up
or anything but Chris Pratt says this
movie has the best musical score out of
every film in the trilogy a big part of
the music stems from yondu finding the
Zune in his junker shop that sort of
paved the way for them to curate the
playlist however they wanted we've
opened it up and allowed for some iconic
songs to come in James Gunn took his
time to really curate the playlist full
of what Chris Pratt describes as sleeper
hits you'll have to leave a comment and
let me know what your favorite song on
the soundtrack is for all of you Chris
Pratt fans out there there was a hyper
realistic life-size version doll of him
somewhere in the prop room for this film
you've probably noticed in the trailer
when nebula was carrying Star-Lord it
was super creepy for Chris to see it for
the first time because it looked so real
he had a really unsettling visceral
reaction to it it was the strangest
thing to see an incredibly lifelike but
Dead version of yourself is something
that I hope no one here ever sees it
definitely
Way Karen Gillen could carry Chris like
that for all those takes they had to do
one thing I really want to know is where
is that doll now who's got that in their
office I know the doll was made out of
foam and it wasn't exactly light yeah I
had to put it down in between take but
it was definitely a lot easier for her
than carrying the actual Chris so one
thing I love about this third
installment is how much focus is on
Rocket we know that Bradley Cooper does
the voice acting but something that
often goes under focused is Sean Gunn's
actual acting when it comes to the
infamous raccoon he spent a ton of hours
doing motion capture for the film that
should definitely not go unnoticed those
eye movements everything that he does
it's all tracked off of Sean's
performance so yeah obviously rocket is
CGI but what we're actually looking at
when we look at his facial expressions
are the incredible acting skills of Sean
Gunn it is an amalgamation of Sean and
Bradley and you know the visual effects
artists so oftentimes especially when it
came to some emotionally poignant
moments the actors would watch Sean's
performance that he did in motion
capture to really understand the
emotional nature of the scene before
acting it out something we get to find
out in this third film is how rocket got
to be who he is and apparently according
to James Gunn we've got to get those
tissue boxes ready because it's a very
sad story a Rocket's backstory is very
sad it all comes back to that childhood
trauma and as time has gone on he's
reacted to that by coming becoming a
tough guy James Gunn feels super
connected to Rocket he used to collect
raccoon figurines when he was a kid so
getting to create this storyline was a
huge emotional element for him
especially given the fact that his own
brother got to play him going through
that Journey that's the reason that I
wanted to finish this movie is to tell
that story he also pulled a lot from his
own childhood Journey that helped create
an extremely personal narrative Through
The Eyes of Rocket Raccoon so as I've
already mentioned James Gunn pulled from
his own childhood experience to write
Rocket's story can I use my anger to
push everybody away from me and you know
use my humor to push everybody away from
me it was a really personal story for
him to tell plus his love of raccoons
and animals in general shifted
throughout the story's narrative in a
big way when he was on his own little
journey growing up he was sort of like
rocket and couldn't let anyone get
emotionally close to him I've learned
that you know you can let people in you
can trust other people sometimes you can
be vulnerable James Gunn worked closely
with Bradley Cooper as well to develop
the right voice and portrayal of the
character apparently James had
envisioned this third movie from the
very beginning and had always called it
a love letter to Rocket once you
understand the origins of all the
behavior it just I think it changes the
way you perceive Bradley Cooper
recommends after learning rocket star
story in the final installment to
actually go back and re-watch the first
two with your new knowledge
unfortunately I can't say that I have
the real but from what I've gathered
there are a ton of fun moments behind
the scenes with the cast and crew thank
God I don't operate the camera for this
movie because if I did it would look
terrible okay but I can't say I wouldn't
watch that version in full though I'm
sure there would be some great behind
the scenes moments captured or Genuine
fans so there's something really sweet
about geeking out on set there was
definitely a Bittersweet note to the
culmination of the film because over
this past decade they've all developed
such a close friendship and bond Will
Poulter went through a huge physical
transformation to play the role of Adam
Warlock he definitely gives major credit
to his team of personal trainers and
people who helped care for his mental
health during the process I have so much
the hard work done for me it was
actually my job just to kind of you know
train and eat there was also a lot of
discussion about his character
psychologically because his birth was
sort of teased at the end of the second
movie so they had to figure out the way
they wanted to take this story they
ended up going with the idea of his
infancy and embracing that aspect so he
had to kind of play up the fact that he
basically has no clue what's going on
and what the difference between right
and wrong is Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 is definitely taking us on an
emotional ride to close out this epic
decade-long chapter we've got Shawn
Gunn's heart-wrenching performance as
Rocket the absolute insane chemistry the
cast has developed over the years and of
course the Chris Pratt doll that I will
be personally scouring eBay for what are
your favorite moments from the Guardians